-Looking good. Looking sharp.
-Good to be back!
-Yes, you're actually back.
-In person.
-The last time we talked,
you guys were --
Actually, you weren't even
together.
You were -- We're all Zooming.
-That's right.
-And that was the first time you
guys had been apart in over --
-Many, many years.
-Oh, yeah.
-Is it 20 years? Because you've
been friends forever.
-Yeah.
The pandemic took us apart
for a little bit over a month.
-Yeah.
-That's when we were getting
together with you over the Zoom.
It was tough.
It was tough on our friendship.
-I was talking to myself a lot.
But I learned a lot about myself
apart from Link.
-But then when you got
back together,
you wanted to do it in
the safest way possible.
-You got to maintain
that social distance.
Six feet.
-Yeah, you brought a photo.
And just for us, I really
appreciate this exclusive photo.
This is you...
-Oh, yeah.
-...meeting for the first time.
There you go. Maintain that --
[ Laughter ]
You can still feel the love.
[ Applause ]
-Yes.
-Those are my arms though.
Rhett had to get an extension.
[ Laughter ]
-Those are your actual arms.
Yeah.
-I get those long arms.
-You just celebrated 10 years
of the show, by the way.
Congratulations.
-Crazy.
-That's amazing.
-A decade.
-10 years, over 2,000 episodes.
-You have nearly 8 billion
views.
Do you know that? Were those
the dreams when you first
started the show 10 years ago?
Like, "Wow, we're gonna hit
8 billion views"?
-Well, we just thought,
"You know what?
If we can enjoy hanging out with
each other for all this time,
let's just start putting that on
the Internet and see if people
can latch on to it."
In the first episode,
we were talking about,
"Hey, this is going to be
something big.
Make this a part of
your daily routine."
And I mean, I think we were just
saying that to pump ourselves.
-Yeah, we were hyping ourselves.
-But it turns out we were, like,
speaking it into existence.
I did not know I had this power.
-Yeah, I mean, because it's been
cool to see
the mythical beasts out there.
They're so supportive of
what we're doing,
and they've grown up over
these past 10 years.
We've had people grow up,
get married.
We've had people get divorced,
which those can be really
interesting because
if you have family that is
watching the show
and they get divorced,
they start two new families.
-Twice as many views.
-That's a great way
to double your fan base.
-Oh, so you double the --
That's how you get to 8 billion.
That's genius.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Brilliantly said.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
You're almost encouraging all of
your fans to get divorced.
You want to hit 16 billion
views.
-But they're starting good,
new families. See?
-Of course.
-I'm a product of divorce.
Look at me.
-Look at you.
Look at how good he turned out.
Fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's a pic.
Here's a pic from your very
first "Good Mythical Morning."
-Haven't changed a bit.
-Haven't changed a bit at all.
Did you always sit on
the same sides, Rhett & Link?
-Yeah. We have always sat as
Rhett & Link in order to
not be confused as
Link & Rhett.
-That's the last thing I want,
is to be confused as him.
-That's the last thing you want.
-But, see, here's the thing.
The way that works out here is
that, you know,
this is the eighth time
we've been here.
Seventh time we've been here
in person.
-Yeah, of course.
-Every single time,
he gets to sit close to you.
-Because you're Rhett
and you're Link?
-Yeah.
-That's the way it works.
-And I'd like to know
what it feels like.
[ Laughter ]
-To sit here?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Will you let me?
-No.
No. No. I like how --
I like the arrangement.
-I don't think I have to
ask for permission.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This feels pretty good.
-Did I just disappear entirely?
-Yes, no one can see you at all,
by the way.
They can't see you.
He is there somewhere.
-Wow.
-How's it feel?
-You're a good-looking guy.
-Thank you. You too.
-Hey.
-It's great to see you, bud.
You're a stud.
-You're going to mess up
the cords in my corduroy.
Get off.
-Alright, alright.
That's all I need.
-"What you want for Christmas?"
-I want to talk about --
You guys are hosting a new show
on the Food Network.
-Yeah.
-I love Food Network.
-After tasting food for like
10 years on
"Good Mythical Morning,"
then Food Network gives you
a show to taste more food.
But we get to leave our studio
and go out on --
I'll call them "adventures."
Behind the scenes of some of
your favorite restaurants.
-Because it's called
"Inside Eats."
-That's right.
-"With Rhett & Link."
So you get on the inside.
-Yeah, we ask questions like,
"Why is The Cheesecake Factory
menu so big?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's a great question.
-"What happened there?
Why is it spiral-bound?"
-"And how do they do that?
How do they pull off
so many items?"
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Like, I know you recently did
one with Chipotle.
-Oh, yes.
-Yes.
Well, see, we think that what
you order at Chipotle
says something about
your personality.
We believe in this so strongly
that we think that we can
actually get to know somebody,
ask them a few questions
and then predict what
their Chipotle order is.
-We can do it for you right now.
-You can -- You can tell what --
-We can predict
your Chipotle order.
Okay, so what is your sign?
-Alright, here we go.
What's going on?
-Focus, Jimmy. What's your sign?
-Alright, do I look straight?
-Look at me.
-Sorry, alright.
-Hold up your left hand
and your right hand.
What's your sign?
-Virgo.
-What's your favorite color?
-Right now, red.
-Okay, and then clasp
your hands.
-What's the worst thing
you've ever done?
[ Laughter ]
-I tried to pull off
cargo shorts once.
[ Laughter ]
I shouldn't have done that.
-Alright.
Those are burrito-grabbing
hands.
I think he's a burrito man.
-Hold on.
Let me test. Grab that forearm.
Oh, you're a burrito man.
-Burrito guy.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-This is ridiculous.
-Look at me deeply in the eyes.
-Yes, I always do.
-Black beans.
-White rice.
-Yes, that's a burrito.
Isn't it?
[ Laughter ]
-Protein.
-Give me an "ah."
-Ah.
-He's a chicken man.
-Chicken man.
Alright, and your left ear,
I'm sorry to say this,
is a little lower
than your right ear.
[ Laughter ]
-So what does that tell you?
-You hate sour cream.
You can't stand sour cream.
-That is true.
I do not like sour cream.
-Right, right.
-Hey, we're professionals.
-It's the ear thing. Yeah.
And then you like it spicy.
-A little spice.
-Okay. This is actually correct.
This is bizarre.
-Yeah, right.
-Okay.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We do this for a living, Jimmy.
-Right, so what you're saying is
my order is,
is a spicy chicken burrito
with --
-White rice, black beans.
-No sour cream.
-That is absolutely correct,
by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is 100% correct.
-We didn't get you one though.
I'm sorry.
-No, you didn't get me one.
Did you ask around or something?
-Of course we didn't ask
your producers ahead of time
what you normally order
from Chipotle.
[ Laughter ]
-I was wondering.
I go, "Oh, my gosh.
Wait a second, you're actually
on -- totally on point."
Someone told you. Perfect.
Alright. Good.
[ Laughter ]
I want to show a clip.
What are we going to see here
for your show?
-Well, we went to Beyond Meat.
-Oh!
[ Audience oohs ]
-You're intrigued now.
-If you've ever seen meat,
it's on the other side of that.
-It's "beyond," yeah. It's like,
"Bed, Bath, and Beyond Meat."
-Right, exactly.
-We kind of went behind the
scenes, got the whole process,
How they make
this plant-based meat.
And we had a little taste test.
-Oh!
-A blind taste test.
-Oh, here's a look.
"Inside Eats with Rhett & Link."
Take a look.
-How much do you like or dislike
the appearance of your sample?
-I like it very much.
-And you don't say your answers
out loud.
-Well, don't listen to me
saying them out loud.
-Well, you said it
at a normal volume.
-We get to sniff it.
-Am I going to get to answer
questions about the cracker?
-The cracker is optional.
It's to cleanse your palate.
-How much do you like
or dislike the flavor?
What was your answer?
-I've got strong opinions,
but the only one I'm sharing
with you out loud
is the one about the cracker.
I enjoyed it extremely.
-How would you describe umami?
-She's a sweet, Southern woman.
[ Laughter ]
-Not "you mommy." Umami.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Sweet, Southern woman."
Rhett & Link, everybody.
"Inside Eats with Rhett & Link"
airs Sundays at 10:30 p.m.
on Food Network.